good day everyone and welcome i'm jack van horn
from the university of virginia please allow me
to welcome you to this edition of our 2020
2021 foundations of biomedical data science
seminar series this lecture is supported by
uva's integrated translation translational
health institute of virginia the uva brain
institute the college of arts and sciences the
school of data science and buy a grant from the
national institutes of general medical sciences
uh it is my delight today to welcome our friend
and colleague um dr neda jahanshad from the
university of southern california in los angeles
california neda is an associate professor of
neurology at the imaging genetic center which is
part of the stevens neuroimaging and informatics
institute at the university of southern california
she holds undergraduate degrees from johns hopkins
university and her phd from the university of
california los angeles dr jahanshad has over 10
years of experience in analyzing brain scans from
large groups of individuals in comparing magnetic
resonance imaging scans of people with and without
brain disorders of all ages much of her research
explores the brain as a network of interconnected
pathways using diffusion weighted mri
a technology which reveals physical connections
between different functional areas of the brain
dr jahanshad also directs the laboratory of
brain ease sciences at usc loebs as it is called
is a collaborative multidisciplinary team which
combines multimodal brain imaging techniques with
advanced computational modeling approaches and
information sciences to better understand the
brain and reliably identify risk factors which
contribute to its decline in aging the lab aims
to ensure that their tools and approaches and
findings bridge international boundaries for
broadest possible applications dr jahanshad
is a key developer for the enigma consortium
which brings together hundreds of researchers from
around the planet these researchers work together
to identify the genetic environmental risk factors
which make the brain susceptible to disease
dr jahanshad's presentation today is entitled
advancing neuroimaging genomics with continuous
team science and as always we are streaming this
lecture live and for recording via youtube and
if you are watching by youtube today thank you so
much for joining us um also our specially selected
2020 2021 biomedical data science innovation
lab participants are strongly encouraged to
submit any questions for dr jahanshad via the chat
feature in their zoom sessions i will synthesize
these questions and i'll ask them on your behalf
during the last 10 minutes or so of the lecture
and so neda thank you so much for doing us the
favor of presenting your work today and we are
excited to hear your presentation thank you so
much dr van horn i'm excited to be here i'm just
going to turn off my video so it's easier for me
to give the presentation and i'll turn it back on
for questions um well thanks everyone as dr
van horn mentioned my talk today is called
advancing our imaging genomics with continuous
team science um uh i have some nih funding and
funding from biogen that's unrelated to the
contents of this talk um so as i'm sure you're all
well aware now especially towards the end of
this seminar series there has been a replication
crisis in brain imaging uh sorry uh hopefully
that i should silence my phone next time um
so what does that um where does that come from
so just a little bit of background most of the
neuroimaging studies that um sort of culminated
in this replication crisis a lot of them had been
in very small sample sizes or and now we're
seeing as uh relatively small between 20 maybe 200
and they were only conducted within single
studies without independent replications and
some of them didn't even address multiple testing
issues well so when going back and trying to
rerun a lot of these tests or trying to replicate
these results claims in many papers did not hold
in addition to some of these technical
uh issues um there's a publication
bias that that often prevents null or
contradictory findings from being reported
so there's opposit potential inflation of effect
sizes uh in these literature-based meta-analyses
where you're really just pulling together um
findings that were uh significant or successful
now um it's obviously uh one of the reasons behind
these small sample sizes is because at least in
brain imaging uh scanning is pretty expensive
it's um approximately six hundred dollars an
hour just for the scan alone um and you
need often times about an hour per subject
so there have been several initiatives over
um the last um almost two decades now uh where
there are multi-center
initiatives that that aim to
coordinate data collection across many sites
and ensure well-powered studies and this
involves some prospective data harmonization
efforts let's say like imaging phantoms
and ensuring that the protocols
across the sites are are the same
these are all exceptional resources
for scientific uh discovery um
but on the other hand what happens to all the data
that was not from these multi-million dollar um
multi-center initiatives all
the all the studies that were
collected before all those uh smaller individual
studies so at the time a lot of uh people were
actually being funded to study some of the same
questions in in regards to brain development
psychiatric disorders aging dementia um oftentimes
in different population and everyone would have
their own protocols and and uh imaging protocols
or maybe different functional tasks so um
the one idea is is can all these individual
smaller studies that were funded to do the same
ultimate analysis what can they be merged
for for more powerful reliable findings
um and could they be merged with each other or
with these newer multi-site initiatives and how
um so that's sort of the basis behind the
enigma consortium which i'm i'm a part of
and so enigma stands for enhancing
neuroimaging genetics through meta-analysis
and i'll get through why this acronym
is not exactly what we do anymore
so enigma started with the idea of of genetics
and especially because neuroimaging genetics
in particular were very susceptible to false
positives and uh you could say well why is that
the case we've had these neuroimaging genetic
studies for you know two two decades now um
uh so we we know some of these candidate
genes so i've just here taken a snapshot of uh
some some papers and this is not to call anyone
out if if they've been involved in these papers
some of them i i've been involved in it's just
at the time we thought we knew a risk factor
for um for brain decline so but but we
actually hadn't double checked there a lot
of them had weak or no statistical correlations
there's a lack of replication lack of power
and if you do a power analysis you need 800 people
to detect a 1 effect and this is a very big effect
for uh for a snip or a single nucleotide uh
variant or or genetic marker um with eighty
percent power at p less than 105 0.05 sorry uh
so if if snips explain just one percent or less
than one percent then why are these imaging um
genetic studies being done in less than 100 people
um that was because we were doing underpowered
candidate neuroimaging genetic studies so we will
see that a lot of these um were in you know about
100 or less participants and sometimes they would
even um test multiple factors but not correct
for them so if you're testing um five domains
you should correct for uh five tests so we'll see
why there was this um this sort of push towards uh
or this decline towards um the crisis because we
weren't um looking at things properly so enigma
began in 2009 initially to identify genetic loci
that reliably contribute to brain structure and
the reason we focused on this genetic aspect is
because genetics offer this direct link to the
underlying biological mechanism which which means
that there are there are easy targets for um for
treatment and at the same time you have the
imaging marker for monitoring and assessing
the efficacy of any treatment um and uh so
it's it's it's important to to keep in mind
um that when you're scanning the genome you
actually have about a million independent common
variants so you're not just doing one test you're
doing a million tests so you need to correct for
those million tests and set your significance
threshold appropriately and that would be
5 times 10 to the negative 8 for a
single genome-wide association study
and it's important to keep in mind that your
power doesn't depend on the the test that
you're doing so yeah mri is more expensive to
collect than let's say some classifying someone
as having a disease or not um but it's not more
powerful so you'll you still need the sample size
and to illustrate that this this
paper looks at the number of subjects
needed for a given number of tests with respect to
the percent variance explained and as i mentioned
a single nucleotide uh genetic marker often
has less than one percent uh variance explained
um oops this got moved so um we
what we would have is actually um
around here if we're doing um a 10 times
10 to the n to the sixth test uh the brain
should actually be around here so we have about
um at least 10 000 individuals that we would need
for a successful genome wide association
test to have the power for it
um but how are we going to get 10 000 scans uh
well uh we'll we as i mentioned we're going to try
and pull all this data from all the all
the smaller studies from around the world
and as i'm sure you're aware a a person
scanned in one scanner is not going to
have the same exact mri image as that same person
scanned in another scanner so this is a an example
of one person scanned at a 1.5 t scanner and then
again um at a three tesla scanner so you can see
if you're familiar with looking at brains you
might know you could probably guess that this is
the same person but you can clearly see that the
brain structure is has different contrast so like
the gray and white matter contrasts are different
some structures are easier to see than others
um so we have these these um these
issues that we're trying to work through
and our first approach is this
analytical harmonization so um
uh we might want to actually uh embrace this
variability in in the in the acquisition you're
not going to necessarily want to have your finding
depend on a given scanner if you're trying to
develop um a medication or trying to monitor
um brain tissue atrophy you don't want that
quantity to have to depend on a single scanner
otherwise everyone in the world who might have
a disorder related to your treatment
or the biomarker would have to go to
a particular location and um we know how difficult
that could that could be uh so so what we decided
to do is just to try and embrace that variability
and harmonize the analysis plan instead so kind of
um select certain metrics to analyze the same
across everyone ensure that quality assurance
is done similarly across sites and have the same
statistical workflow and this works exceptionally
well for this coordinated meta-analysis that we
did um and to to pool all this data we want to
ensure that the metrics that were extracting
uh the brain metrics um are derived reliably
from scans regardless of how they are required
again we're trying to embrace this variability so
but we do want to make sure that whatever measures
we're extracting are reliable um regardless of
uh of the scanner so before we distribute our
protocols and let people know what what measures
we're trying to extract we need to test those
measures are those measures extracted reliably
and are they reliably reliable and by that i mean
again does it depend on a single scanner or can
we reliably extract this measure across different
scanners and we'll have often four or five sites
beta test any protocols make sure that everything
works if there are any frequently asked questions
we'll make note of that and try and troubleshoot
it and improve our protocols and once the quality
assurance measures are in place then we can
send them out so um one tool to start with
um many imaging uh many many brain imaging sites
around the world are familiar with these common
uh tools such as free surfer for cortical analyses
so um before we we say hi everyone run free surfer
we make sure to test whether they're there they
the measures we're looking at are reliable so
is there high intraclass correlation so if
you do a test re-test analysis at different
scanning sites is it reliable regardless and
do we have quality control protocols and then
so we put that into place so ways that individuals
can look for errors in the outcome like make sure
the whole cortex is extracted so we have
created cortical quality control protocols
that we've also distributed alongside the analysis
plan so we have um several imaging protocols
the first one i mentioned
is based on on free surfer
but there are other ones based on diffusion tensor
imaging or more detailed analyses of shape we
recently um a group in germany that we work
closely with has developed a harmonized analysis
of fmri processing which could be used for
resting state and also for task-based fmri
so going back into that the the free surfer
protocols i'm going to go through
and it's a recent example of how we
we use this and to pool all the data so the
latest genome-wide association study we did
was entitled the genetic architecture of the human
cortex and it was published in science last year
so we asked the question can we identify
these genetic variants that are associated
with just normal variation in portable
surface area thickness as a whole and also
these regional patterns so at each site um we
ran the geoass of particle structure so again
we're making use of the not only the the data
sets at each site but also the computational
infrastructure so we're doing this distributed
analysis where each site does the statistical
analysis does all the computation and
then the results are all pulled together
um so once all the sites have done the analysis
um they send only their results not the images
or the genetics themselves um to a centralized
location where we do the meta-analysis
and we do some quality control uh tests on
top of that um and then once we pull all
the data together and make sure that there are
no quality issues we found over 200 uh genetic
regions that are associated with um either one
trait surface area or thickness or those traits in
particular regions um and we found that actually
most loci were unique to a particular brain or
trait so we do see this regional patterning
of effects we saw that the the cortical um
the genetic architecture of the cortical measures
are actually pretty different so surface area
was a little bit different than thickness
with with surface area finding several
more regions of genetic association
and within surface area actually we see this
regional patterning where we found a lot more
genetic associations with areas of the
occipital lobe than some of the other regions
so we have this polygenic polygenicity
of the occipital lobe where there are
more genes associated with that or
genetic loci and you can actually
take the full genome-wide results so not looking
at the significant loci only but really the
across all a million independent regions
and correlate those with genetic results of
other traits and we actually see a positive
correlation between as you might expect greater
surface area and greater educational attainment
and this is a genetic correlation and also
a negative correlation between traits such as adhd
and insomnia where lower surface area correlates
or genetic risk for lower surface area correlates
with genetic risk for adhd and insomnia
and interestingly there's a positive correlation
with with parkinson's disease where genetic risk
for higher surface area also correlates with
genetic risk for increased risk of parkinson's
so this reproducibility is actually an issue
across these biomedical fields not just genetics
and our our our goal is not to just focus
on genetics but to ensure that this improved
disability is something that we can evaluate
across all of the neuroimaging sciences um so we
extend these methods um far beyond genetics
to look at a series of disorders um diseases
and various conditions even in normal
uh and normal developments and um and
and healthy individuals so um we are
uh using these these protocols that
are are similar across these working groups so the
same quality control protocols the same analyses
we are able to take the results and compare them
to each other so you get this interesting overview
of how different disorders for example might have
different effects on the brain and these are all
conducted using similar protocols and each one of
these analyses had over a thousand participants
um and as i mentioned it's not our work is
not just limited to free surfer and cortical
uh surface area or thickness but we've also
done some work with diffusion tensor imaging um
and we're not only looking for
reliable effects across the
data that we're using um but this was a
an interesting application where after
we published this paper uh with i think
over over 30 sites participating in finding
globally reduced or lower fa in schizophrenia
participants versus controls a separate consortium
a separate multi-site consortium with only
japanese sites found very similar results
and we were able to look at these side by side
and the the other consortium also used exactly the
same imaging protocols which we had made public so
um that's kind of a brief overview of a lot of the
enigma work but there's plenty more so if
you're interested in any of um the conditions
or disorders or studying any of the traits that
that you saw in that plot do reach out because
there's always room um for additional analyses
and that sort of gets into my next uh aspect of
how we're extending some of these work and that's
to look at really the continuous portion of this
um as i mentioned each you know every time we're
presenting work on enigma there might be someone
who um has a data set that they would like
to contribute to the these ongoing analyses
so we have this um continuous analysis uh
sort of um where as more and more uh groups
are joining our sample size is growing and and
with greater sample size you have more power
to detect effects uh sometimes you can detect
uh sort of the same effect but with more power
so this is an example of our first study looking
at doing a genome-wide association for hippocampal
volume we had about 8 000 individual scans
across all the data sets and this was our top hit
was just below the significance threshold uh
in a second uh analysis there were um 5 000
more uh scans that were had been contributed
from many sites around the world and that top
hit was now past that significant threshold
and was significant and very recently the data
the sample size doubled and you can
see this this evolution of significance
um in these findings as we're continuing
these analyses a lot of them have are repeated
um you're you're seeing this sort of evolution in
results and not all of them are in this direction
sometimes you'll see a result that might have
gone away once more samples were added so it's
important to have this this evolution of knowledge
and that refining our understanding of um
of these tests that we're doing so um we're
developing this sort of infrastructure to
accommodate for these continuous analyses
as there's more and more data being held
being contributed or even collected um can we
do what we're doing in a continuous manner um
sort of automatically actually so can we um
uh so we're working with um researchers at
the information sciences institute at usc to
develop this sort of workflow um and just to
give you a little bit of background so this is a
new um infrastructure that we're calling neurodisk
and there's a website that will be made
public very soon um we ask a hypothesis
uh which is a question that we want to to test
um and this is linked with a line of inquiry
that will look for data uh in this wiki that
we've developed um and the the wiki has uh
certain properties uh it has a given ontology
and the data sets are annotated to include
features for for knowing whether or not that data
set would be included in a particular hypothesis
and and so we can look for data that would match
our hypothesis and then we have um workflows let's
see analyses statistical analyses um in a separate
system that gets called and all that together
uh allows us to uh continuously update our our
our knowledge so here's an example let's ask a
hypothesis this is based on the results of the
cortical genetics paper that i that i mentioned
so let's let's ask for example is the effect size
of um this genetic variant which was actually our
top genetic variant on the surface area of the
precentral cortex is it associated with age
so that triggers this line of inquiry
which which says okay we're looking for
um the effect size of a particular genotype on a
certain brain imaging trait uh and we're looking
to see if that's associated with the demographic
which in our case would be age so that triggers
um a lookup of our wiki uh so our meta
wiki where we have all the annotations
um and as and also the um the statistical uh
analysis gets run with all the data that it finds
and so this um this allows this sort of
continuous evolution so if uh you missed
your chance to participate in a study that was
published you could we have the protocols in place
in terms of the imaging protocol so you know to
run those you have the statistical protocols also
which are made public and those results can get
integrated even if the data doesn't get shared
through and by the data i mean the
individual subject level data which is often
sometimes shareable sometimes not so
we we work under the assumption that it
doesn't always need to be shared at the individual
subject level so even if that is not the case you
could still contribute results and be a part
of this continued workflow um and as an example
uh we uh we ran the the results of our um again
cortical uh genetic paper with and without
the largest sample that we had which was
the uk biobank um so if that data set got
added in later we have an evolution of the results
so these are the forest plots which show each
individual cohort that participated and then after
we add the uk biobank you see this additional um
row here and in our our example of looking at the
association with age or mean age of the cohort
we plot mean age on the x-axis and the effect
size the y-axis and you see the trend line um
so they evolve after the
addition of your data sets
so we also have um uh other uh extensions and
initiatives um including uh statistical and
image harmonization for beyond meta-analysis so if
you can share the individual subject level data um
you know what what can we do so um
beyond uh meta analysis and that that's
exactly what i mean basically you're no
longer meta analyzing statistical results
from individual groups but you have individual
subject level data from all sites and you have
essentially a mega analysis where all the data are
can be joined uh and you can look for um uh
it actually allows to look for more than um
for let's say rare or occurrences
so in this case um in this epilepsy
diffusion paper that we published in brain
last year the the individual uh subject level
uh diffusion measures uh were all pooled to
look for effects of uh subtypes of epilepsy
and some of these subtypes are not as common um
as others so you would not you might get let's say
three or four individuals within a particular
cohort that have this subtype but when you're
in in that three or four is certainly not enough
to do such a well-powered statistical test
even if it will be cooled with with other data
later or other effect sides later so by pulling
these rare subtypes together in one big cohort
then you can do a more powerful test um and um you
uh have to in some sense harmonize the the data
sets to account for the scanner variability that
we talked about earlier so in this case we did
a statistical harmonization where if you can see
here before the harmonization the distribution for
each site is a different color in this plot and
you see how they're basically all over the place
for fa yet every site has its own distribution and
for those familiar with diffusion imaging you
know that that makes perfect sense because
these values are are uh essentially um uh only
dependent on on the the acquisition of the image
uh so after this this combat statistical
correction we see that all the the data sites um
all the sites have their data distributions
were with similar means and variance
so that's how we were able to to do these
analyses um and uh adjust for these side effects
um so as i uh explained um the meta-analysis
is where the stats are run at the
individual sites and the results are merged
and it does allow for the subject level data to
remain local so if it cannot be shared um then
then then that's fine um and then on the other
hand the mega analysis the subject level data
are pulled together and then the analysis is run
on the cohort or the huge data sample as a whole
um so we are harmonization is actually a very
active area of study this is another example of
how statistical harmonization can be used we have
a paper out on that archive looking at different
stages of parkinson's disease and again um not
all cohorts collect uh you know or are looking at
parkinson's patients or people with parkinson's
at all these different stages so you might have
um lower frequency of certain stages at
certain sites and by pulling all the data
and doing harmonization trying to account for
for these site effects we're able to um focus
our statistical analyses on on these subgroups
of individuals at different homeowner stages
but harmonization is actually
a very active area of study
and there are um some deep learning methods
that are now being uh used to try and uh
remove the site effect um so one uh one area that
we've been working on uh maintain lou in my group
um has this new uh method
based on stargans 2 where each
if you see here the the static images represent
the original image at the top row um and then the
bottom row represents um the that same subject
image harmonized to a another scan um so what
you're seeing kind of move up here this is what
we're harmonizing too we're trying to match
the style of these these any other image so you
can you can see that the contrast uh changes but
you're not adjusting uh structure at all so you
it should still be the same individual but perhaps
look like it was scanned at a different
scanner another approach could be this is
again another active area of study whether we can
derive acquisition and variant imaging traits so
if you were to extract the mid-sagittal corpus
callosum from from individual standard different
scanners the thickness might be very dependent
on the voxel size of the image um but but
the uh the curvature might be something
that you could extract reliably
um across scans so this is something we're
actively working on in my group uh alyssa has
published a sifying paper a couple years
ago and now we have a deep learning approach
for this extraction and deriving these these
measures of curvature we're also working on on
better methods for extracting information
from diffusion imaging as well
and talia near in my group showed that um
fractional and isotropy or fa derive from the
tensor distribution function which essentially
is um looking at all the possible tensors that
you can fit to a given voxel instead of the best
one which is usually done with the standard dti
um but that actually gives a more uh
homogeneous distribution across sites than um
than the standard fa alone so that was
that was interesting as well and uh
all this um all this harmonization and
all this like um uh ensuring common
protocols and statistical approaches and quality
control measures across sites also allows us to
ask questions across across these groups that
maybe we couldn't equate we couldn't ask before
so one uh one nice thing about this is that
it does open the door for looking at um
cross disorder or or trans diagnostic effects
so um if there are symptoms or outcomes that
are similar across different uh conditions or
disorders maybe we could look across those and um
not have a disorder specific analysis
that we're doing so suicidal thoughts
and behaviors are common across
many mental illnesses and we are
using the statistical and image
harmonization efforts to address
um address this and pool the data together
and account for the fact that there are um
there's a low base rate of suicide attempts
uh in in a given collected cohort so
um even though it's rare it's obviously a very big
problem so we need these harmonization methods to
be able to pull the data to be able to ask these
questions and have the power um to answer the
questions reliably so this is one initiative
that we're currently working on is the uh
suicidal thoughts and behaviors group which again
is not limited to a particular disease or disorder
but is trying to look across all of them to to be
able to identify the neurobiological signatures of
a suicidal traits um and and other factors that
might um associate with those so um right now
we have been able to look across various disorders
including schizophrenia bipolar a major depression
we do have some ocd and ptsd participants as well
and we're not just comparing individuals who've
had suicidal attempts with healthy
controls but now we have clinical controls
where these are individuals that have the same
diagnoses but might not have made a suicide
attempt or do not have suicidal ideations so
this is uh an active area of work um and um
i i won't present the results because these
are being uh updated regularly so in summary
uh sort of this this international multi-site
collaboration that we're doing has really uh ex
given us an opportunity to work um in a
well-powered environment for for neuroscience
with uh computational efficiency especially if
um for the meta analysis studies where you have
the computation being done in a distributed manner
and also um is an opportunity to to really look um
at this open science and sharing of information
and to to collaborate to ensure reproducibility
and get these well-powered results and that and of
course that's that's related to the team science
as well um and and in recent years it's really
been um opened up new i think technical questions
as well how do we best harmonize the data and
how do we advance um neuroscientific discovery
uh so um there are hundreds of people in enigma
and um i would want to thank them all but i
don't think you want to sit through that
um so i uh will refer you to this this
recent review paper if you're interested
in learning more this is published in
translational psychiatry where it describes
the last um 10 years of our work in enigma
and thank you to the the lab members and to the
folks whose results i i did present today um
and thanks and with that i'm happy to answer any
questions neda thank you so much for summarizing
uh enigma for us and uh for and all the work that
you guys have been doing um through enigma it's
uh a fine example of a team science writ large
uh around the planet it's a really a great um
kind of group resource uh is a great example
of that uh kind of done at uh at scale if you
will um i like the idea of you know you can
touching on the notion of publication bias
this is something i've looked at myself um where
you know we've been we've had this as a problem
in neuroimaging for since its inception where
you know i can remember the early days of neural
imaging and the certain software packages who will
remain nameless where they hard coded the number
of subjects that you are permitted to use uh in
their software at n equals six and you know when
you we're trying to do this uh the the the groups
that would use the software um to you know for
software like that with these small sample sizes
you know they were just very prolific so they're
flooding the literature with these small uh sample
sizes and of course they're only reporting on
the stuff that was statistically significant
so early on we came out of the shoot with a
publication bias problem um and it's interesting
to see enigma taking this really kind of global
planetary if you will approach to bringing people
together around this i have a couple of questions
um one of them is are there have you noticed
any site-based differences you know i know
that the whole effort is to kind of grab all
the data and pool it into one big sample but
i'm also kind of curious about do you see
say country by country based differences uh
you know site by site based differences you know
are those evidence and how do you adjust for them
there are huge differences um
and one example i think that that
sticks out in my mind is this recent work
that we published earlier this year on our
hiv collaboration so we have many sites in the
u.s we had a couple or one site in in europe um
and ascent most of the us-based sites were or
majority male uh so um between i'd say 70 to 100
of the participants at each and the individual
u.s sites were male and we also had a cohort in
south africa and um that one was largely female
that was the only one that was largely female
so so we see these these these differences that
are not only based on the imaging acquisition at
these different sites but the recruitment uh
and i think that is um an important thing to
be aware of in these harmonization approaches
because a lot of the harmonization approaches
attempt to statistically match the distributions
but maybe they're not meant to be statistically
matched maybe there are biological differences in
these cohorts that should be taken into account
so this is a very good question because it's
a it's an open area of research and it's a
challenge that we're facing is a lot of times we
we might you know we might ask what a proportion
of um the cohort is male or female but there might
be information that we don't ask and we don't know
about but there are clear differences between um
like ethnic groups or countries or just the so
yeah it's the things we don't know i think that i
mean it's such an interesting thing because with
the the way in which enigma has approached this
which is you know laudable because it's clearly
been very productive in a maybe a more traditional
literature-based meta-analysis where you're
gathering you know trying to estimate effect
sizes from particular studies in a literature
you can also incorporate the study kind of factors
that went into the contra the creation of that
effect size right the end result and it could
be diagnostic criteria differences for mri it
could be trte differences or contrast related
differences it could be things like the you
know the proportion of males and females in the
sample as you point out um in a meta-analyses i've
done these are somewhat dated now that um they
we found a statistical correlation between the
urine the size of the effect and the year in which
the study was done and apparently in the example
i did ages ago apparently this is a common thing
that the early effect sizes tend to be larger and
as you get better at doing those studies and you
incorporate more controls to them that the effect
sizes get smaller uh one additional thing which
was kind of ironic i suppose from an enigma point
of view is that we found that uh the the size of
the effect was also inversely correlated with the
number of authors on the paper which we thought
was kind of interesting from a from a sociology
of science point of view but anyway it it would
be very interesting to explore some of those
study factors because you may have like you know
country by country differences in for example
how parkinson's is defined or how alzheimer's is
diagnosed or what have you absolutely um i i agree
there are certainly differences but at the same
time um you know you know one of the things we're
trying to do is embrace those differences we're
not trying to solve um oh absolutely climbers in
one location only you know absolutely i mean
you know hopefully these things are you know
they're random enough that you can average over
them and uh and and be able to to do okay um one
of the things which i just correct me if i'm wrong
but that um the genome-wide association work that
you're doing is is that's largely snip based upon
snips um snip related uh genomics um is there any
opportunity um for enigma to adapt to more full
genome sequence technologies as they become more
readily available so there are there are efforts
looking at um rare variants for example and that
or or copy number variants or um like
22q deletion is its own working group
uh so we do have efforts outside of just the full
genome wide screen um whole genome to uh to really
make the most of of that entire genome
screening um you would and look across uh
across it in an unbiased way we do not have
the sample sizes in your imaging to do that
yet yeah there might be ways as i mentioned to
kind of look um at you know maybe uh use the whole
genome to look at regions around common variants
that we found significant to look for causal
loci or or um really sort of pinpoint um some
of the genetic factors but in terms of screening
whole genome um i'm not sure if if uh there
are fields that aren't there yet even not just
um you mentioned the word uh commonalities
which is kind of interesting i'm curious if
you guys have um a lot of the analyses and all
the working groups you know they seem to be very
disease specific and i think you sort of hinted at
this in part of your uh presentation about trying
to do it irrespective of disease and look for say
commonalities across these different diagnostic
distinctions to see if you can't almost like
anneal different disease kind of profiles
into more common ones does that make sense you
know what i mean um where for example two diseases
may be somewhat similar so similar enough that
their distributions overlap in some way and i
was just curious if you guys have attempted to do
anything like that yeah there so there are some
a lot more cross-diagnostic work now and sort
of trans diagnostic as i mentioned with suicidal
ideation and attempt work um but there are efforts
to to try and look at symptom profiles across
different disorders like there's there's currently
an effort to uh pull uh the data from groups that
have studied uh depression or major depression
bipolar and schizophrenia into one and kind and
look for effects of let's say antidepressants
across across these individuals or look for
common profiles um look for what distinguishes
uh bipolar from uh major depression in terms of
brain circuitry and there are current efforts
um that have really over the last like year or
two really taken off once the sample size
were large enough to work with what um
clearly enigma is doing a great job at identifying
these effects um you know and linking things to
particular gene profiles um and obviously
the sample size just keeps getting larger
um is enigma um the results from enigma these
results of these studies do you know if any of
the studies are being used to inform clinical
treatments for any of these disorders that's a
really good question i think there are efforts to
try and get there um a lot of our first uh sets
of papers were really to establish that this data
could even be pulled together and that we can look
for these common trends across like you said the
different criteria for diagnosis or the different
definitions of certain symptoms across across
the world and now that we're seeing that that
is possible and that is feasible that's now
there are efforts others uh to to to answer
see if we can try and answer the next questions is
like what why would some people respond to certain
treatments and not others what does that treatment
you know do to the brain and i think that will
open the door for um clinical trials and more
translational clinical work you mentioned
mega analyses uh you know pooling not just the
derived metrics but actually going and getting
the actual scans and doing a big combined massive
analysis what sort of resources would you expect
or maybe you're experienced with needing in order
to carry out those kind of analyses is this like
a cloud only based thing that you can only like
send it to amazon for uh if you can you do this
on your laptop you know what do you need so it
depends on the type of mega analysis so i think by
mega i don't necessarily mean the scan as a whole
but it could even be the derived features the the
meta was more the statistics but the mega could be
like just having hippocampal volume across all the
individuals so it i think a lot of people have
been making proposals based on their resources
right if they don't have the computational ability
to have 10 000 full uh sets of diffusion imaging
then that's not what they're going to work with
um but yeah they're i think this this network
and the trust and the also the push from the
funding bodies in some countries and not others
to share data um has really helped sort of drive
some of these mega uh analytical approaches which
is kind of brings me to my kind of last question
i was very interested in your comments on this is
enigma is this fine example of team science in
action writ large and i'm curious what sort of
lessons learned you might be able to share with
you know us about you know how it's how it's gone
like what's going right what are the strengths
what are the weaknesses or maybe room for
improvement in um you know big scale team science
like this so i think um i think you have to go in
you know making your proposal knowing that it's
going to take a lot longer to do the uh the work
uh then you think um there's the bottleneck is
always going to be the slowest person to respond
and the person to send the data wrong or or
maybe not in the correct format that you asked
and i think what it has um has really helped us
understand some um some common errors that we look
for so if we uh you know um say all right everyone
code um you know certain group of patients as one
and the controls is zero there might be
some group that will do it the other way so
how can we check for that um using stats
or or uh different different profiles um uh
males and females were one which had been
coded uh one way in one group and then
another way in the rest of the groups
and we were able to look for main trends
cranial volume to to correct to to understand
that the coding had been mismatched
so i think knowing that you have to have another
level of quality control when you're doing
these these pooled analyses um is i think has been
a benefit because it provides more assurance that
what we're what we're doing is meaningful and
has hopefully less noise than it would otherwise
and uh yeah i think i think we've all learned
over the past year that a lot of this you don't
have to do research with the people you know in
an office next door to you but you really are
able to work with people all over the world
and it's just as easy as working with people um
at the same university so um yeah i think we
we perfected zoom way before most people had heard
of it you're early adopters yeah neda jahanshad
thank you so very much for sharing uh your work
with us and all the interesting things you guys
are doing in team science and meta-analysis and uh
full uh genome-wide association studies in neural
imaging uh super exciting very pioneering work
and uh thank you and all your team members for uh
do the work that you guys are doing um i
want to thank everybody who tuned in today
and uh we'll look forward to seeing you next
week thanks everybody have a good weekend